خلونا نبدا ساعاتنا الثانيه بالحديث عن
وظائف في هذه الوظائف خلص ستندثر لن تكون
موجوده بعد سنوات هذا ما يتوقع احد كبار
اقتصاديه العالم ماركوبان اللي قال بانه
السبب في حقيقه الامر هو اللي تكلمنا عليه
امس الذكاء الاصطناعي يرى انه القدرات
المتزايده لهذا الذكاء الاصطناعي ستجعل
الكثير من الوظائف مستقبلا بلا قيمه حتى
تلك المتعلقه
ببرمجه الكمبيوتر بالفعل هذه الخطوره تدفع
اليوم الى التذمر والاحتجاج فمثلا كتاب
هوليود بداوا احتجاجا كبيرا على مساله
مشاركه الذكاء الاصطناعي في كتابه النصوص
الادبيه الامر الذي يجعل مهنتهم بائره في
المستقبل كل ذلك يدفع طبعا لتساؤل مهم عن
مصير جيل كامل يتعلم اليوم اشياء ربما لن
تكون نافعه له في المستقبل الذكاء
الاصطناعي يحتل وسيحتل ايضا مستقبلا جزءا
كبير من عالم الاعمال لكن المزيد حول
الوظائف المهدده في المستقبل مع زميل
المذيعين برا يا لميس
بحسب جولدن اكثر من 300 مليون وظيفه بدوام
كامل حول العالم ستتاثر نتيجه التطورات
المتسارعه في حقل الذكاء الاصطناعي وبحسب
وظيفه عامل المصنع تاتي على راس هذه
القائمه في الوظائف المهدده في الاختفاء
بفعل الذكاء الاصطناعي
حيث الروبوتات مكان العاملين كذلك وظيفه
السعي او موصل الطلبات قد تختفي مستقبلا
حيث تتجه الى الاتمته واستخدام الروبوتات
بشكل متسارع والتجارب تحقق نجاحا ملفتا
ولن يكون هناك مكان لمحللي البيانات
والاستثمار فهؤلاء سيكون الاستغناء عنهم
بالتعاون مع الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي سيصبح
قادرا على جمع وتحليل وتصنيف البيانات
بافضل طريقه ممكنه وكذلك فان وظيفه خدمه
الزبائن ستكون عرضه للانتهاء بشكل كبير
بسبب الروبوتات التي تحتل مكان العاملين
فيها من السعوديه سالنا الناس ما هي وظائف
المستقبل برايك نتابع الاجابات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يعني عندك مثلا الوظائف الكمبيوتر اللغه
الانجليزيه اداره الاعمال البنوك
انشاءات كل هذه الطلب يحتاج يعني اكثر من
المتخصصات الثانيه اعتقد الذكاء الاصطناعي
والامن السيبراني خلنا نقول كل شيء فيه
كمبيوتر
وصناعه يعني الصناعات بعد الذكاء
الاصطناعي وبعدين الصناعات والله ممكن
المتحكمين في الذكاء الاصطناعي هم اللي
لهم مستقبل عاد بالنسبه لي خاصه في
السعوديه السياحه السعوديه مهتمه في
السياحه البزنس
الاهم اتوقع السياحه السياحه الفتره
القادمه بمشيئه الله يعني
[موسيقى]
معنى الان مشاهدينا من الرياض بندر السفير
الكاتب المختص بالموارد البشريه اهلا بك
يا بندر معنا السفير بندر الصفير اسفه على
اذا يعني لفصل اسمك بطريقه خاطئه اهلا بك
معنا يا بندر في صباح العربيه
تسمعني اهلا وسهلا فيك احييك اختي عادل
اهلا وسهلا حياك الله انا اسمعكم
اهلا وسهلا فيكم الساده المشاهدين اهلا
فيك قبل ما نتحدث عن شو هي الوظائف اللي
ممكن تنقرض او يعني لن تكون موجوده في
السنوات القادمه اسالك عن عمليه التحول هل
رح تكون بين ليلى وضحاها ام انه ممكن تاخذ
وقت خصوصا فيما يتعلق بالوظائف اللي الها
علاقه بتكنولوجيا والكمبيوتر لانه حتى في
منتدى الاقتصادي العالمي كان هناك تصريحات
خرجت تتحدث عن انه الموضوع اصلا سيحصل ما
بين او على مدى ما بين عشره ل 15 الى 20
عام هذا موضوع التحول
ولكن في ذات الوقت ممكن انه يكون في دمج
ما بين البشر
والاي اي اي في وظائف في المستقبل ايضا
طيب خلينا بالبدايه نتكلم عنه هذا موضوع
موضوع جميل ولن يتوقف الحديث عنه
وباذن الله يعني اخوي عادل اختي راوي
بنتقاعد بتوقيت مناسب لن التغيير لسينكشف
على كثير من الوظائف باذن الله ما راح
يكون في الاطار الزمني الضيق
طبعا طبعا يعني خلينا نتكلم
اي لا تونا بس بدون ما نقول الاعمار طال
عمرك هنالك حقائق في هذا الموضوع هنالك
حقائق وهنالك تكهنات وتوقعات في حقيقه
نعيشها اللي هي تقنيه تكشف لنا كثير من
الوظائف لو نعود للوراء عده سنوات ما كنا
نستطيع استضافه ضيوف
بهذه البرامج من خلال الا من خلال عده
تطبيقات
فبالتالي هنالك تقنيه قاعدين نعيشها بشكل
سريع تغير وستخفي كثير من الوظائف هذه
حقيقه نعيشها وهنالك توقعات التوقعات هذه
انه في مجموعه من الوظائف ستختفي فعلا لكن
انا اطلعت على الخبر على العربيه نت في
حقائق مذكوره يعني منتدى الاقتصادي يقول
لك انه في 97 مليون وظيفه في عام 2025
وظيفه جديده نصف الوظائف الحاليه لنعمل
فيها بالعشر سنوات القادمه ستختفي لكن
حتما ستظهر مكانها وظائف اخرى
طيب بندر خليني اسالك انه من عهد ترامب
جديد من عهد ترامب اذا سمحت لي كان هناك
تلويح بانه الشهاده لم تعد مهمه المهم
المهاره او الخبره هذين العنصرين سهلوا
انه في وظائف بالفعل
ستندثر وما لا داعي هذا التحصيل العلمي
الكبير وفي وظائف ثانيه انه لا يقول لك
والله هذه المهاره اللي موجوده باليد او
الحرفيه هذه لن تندثر بسهوله توافق على
هالشي
مئه بالمئه هنالك بعض الوظائف وليس اغلبها
بعض الوظائف لا لم تعد تعتمد على شهادات
جامعيه بينما تتطلب مهارات معينه هنالك
وظائف انكشفت مثلا بشكل التقليدي اليدوي
اختفى اصبح يعتمد على الروبوت بشكل كبير
الا لما نتكلم على حتى القياده معرضه
للاختفاء هنا لقياده ذاتيه يتكلم حتى على
المراسلات التقليديه اصبح الايميل الى
اخره طيب اذا هيك بندر يعني حابين نعرف شو
هي الوظائف اللي ستندثر مثلا طيار محامي
مذيع
الله يبشرك بالخير اذا سامعني يا بندر
حابين نعرف نوجه اطفالنا الجديد ليدرسوا
انا مثلا ابني عمره 16 سنه ممكن عم بفكر
ما بين هندسه وما بين
محاماه ولكن ما بعرف اذا رح تكون هاي
الوظائف موجوده في المستقبل ام لا
يعني الان مثلا اذا سمحتي لي المحاماه
مثلا اصبحت العديد من التطبيقات تجيب على
كثير من التساؤلات القانونيه فمعناها بدات
هذه المهنه تدخل مرحله خطيره الان هل
معناها ستندثر ممكن لا لكن خلونا نتكلم
انه الاثر خلال عشره وعشرين سنه انا اطلعت
على الخبر اللي نشر على العربيه نت طبعا
في مبالغه بعض التكهنات يعني لانها مرتبطه
بامور اخرى مثلا لو ننظر للصراع الامريكي
الصيني خلال السنوات الماضيه احد جوانبه
جوانب متعلقه بالبيانات والتقنيه فبالتالي
السياسه ستؤثر على بعض التطبيقات التقنيه
وتوجيهها الى اطار معين ايضا انه نحكم على
انتاجيه معينه انه هذه الوظيفه ممكن
تستبدلها تقنيه ولا لا حتما ما هو شيء سهل
ويبان في سنه سنتين ردا على سؤالك اختي
راويه الامور البرمجيات تحليل البيانات
الذكاء الاصطناعي والان طبعا في جهود
كبيره جدا وزارات تعليم بالمنطقه باضافه
هذه التخصصات البيانات الضخمه نتكلم على
حتى الاي اي او الذكاء الاصطناعي هذا
النوع من التخصصات اللي
يصعب او عفوا يسهل استبدال اي وظيفه يدويه
تقليديه
شكرا جزيلا لك بندرس
بالموارد البشريه كان معنى شكرا لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات